hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery Deadpool review don't
worry everyone can enjoy the tacos no
spoilers I'll do a separate video with
Easter eggs and all that so let's just
get to it
the movie was awesome you've probably
been hearing everyone talk about how
much they loved it it's great it's a
little unfair to more mainstream comic
book movies like x-men apocalypse or the
Marvel movies that you know are made for
families I think the Deadpool got to
have a little bit more fun because it
was rated R no there is no way the film
would have worked if they would have
done a pg-13 cut Deadpool is a hilarious
character but most of the humor
especially the schmaltzy jokes the jokes
that were dumb but meant to be dumb on
purpose only worked because they came
during very WTF moments so Deadpool just
making a string of really stupid jokes
isn't that much fun but when he does it
while he's splattering people's brains
that's when it reaches peak funny so
like you want the pg-13 version it's
just him walking around telling stupid
jokes
there's no brains getting splattered and
it all falls down but that being said
just kind of working through the film
from start to finish the title sequence
was amazing
I'm so happy that Foxx let them do the
things that they did because somebody in
a suit sitting in an office somewhere
had to approve everything they did and
they spend most of the movie making fun
of Fox making fun of x-men making fun of
themselves making fun of Ryan Reynolds
for that matter there are a lot of
superhero movies that are
tongue-in-cheek
guardians of the galaxy has a lot of
humor like that making fun of typical
tropes that you see in superhero films
but nobody does it better than Deadpool
and there's gonna be no other film this
year or even maybe next year that's
gonna do it as well as Deadpool did
without thinking about the big x-men
universe and all the meta stuff that's
going on it's a good small superhero
film by itself I think originally it was
designed to be this big wonderful gift
to the fans so if it wasn't super
successful it would have totally worked
on its own it could be off in its little
weird corner of the x-men universe but
they also wrote it so that you can
interpret it the other way if things
went really well they could totally
cross them over with the other films
anytime they wanted now a lot of that
gets into sequel talk so I'll talk about
that later because they have already
greenlit the sequel and there's a few
foregone conclusions about what's going
to be happening in that but I thought
all the actors did a great job even Ajax
the actor who plays Ajax is also like
the new transporter guy that movie's not
very successful but his character was
written as a good foil in the movie
the actor did a good job bringing that
across it pulls a killer he's a terrible
person but Ajax is the bad guy it's the
same deal with Suicide Squad bad people
taking down evil people Gina Carano was
great a lot of you have probably seen
the trailer clips of her fighting
Colossus I felt like they wrote in a lot
of her scenes to let her take advantage
of her skills as an MMA fighter like
okay we're gonna let you have some fun
you're gonna be fighting a big-ass x-men
he's super strong but your character is
gonna be badass too and she's pretty
close to her characterization in the
comics they did change a few things
about the Deadpool story in the comics
about the way he got the name and some
of the supporting cast like copycat she
was a lot of fun in the way they wrote
the character was great too it's very
different from the way copycat is
written in the comics if you go back to
old-school Deadpool she's really not
that nice of a person Morena Baccarin
makes it totally believable though Wayne
Wilson and copycat as they get together
are two terrible people that just
recognize each other's flaws your brand
of crazy just works with my brand of
crazy so let's get together one of the
big surprises for me is TJ Miller
because he typically plays characters
that are really hard to like like if you
watched Silicon Valley he plays a very
unlikable character so seeing how well
he worked in Deadpool was a bit of a
surprise but he is a really good
comedian it's just that the characters
that he normally plays are douchebags
but he was great he talked a lot about
how he and Ryan Reynolds improves a lot
of their lines like when he was
insulting Deadpool when he ripped the
mask off you get the sense that a lot of
the jokes in the movie were created that
way with Ryan Reynolds just firing them
out of the machine gun that is his head
and if you didn't see the Deadpool
videos that I posted over the weekend TJ
Miller did say that there would be a
director's cut maybe way more hardcore
than the theatrical release so I think
mostly that's just them swapping out
even dirtier jokes but even with all the
changes to the characters in the
backstory it still totally works as a
film and it's totally true to the soul
of the character is it the greatest
superhero movie of all time no it is not
definitely not but it is one of the best
superhero films of the year I think it
came during the right time like even if
you're a little kid watching me do this
video like you're not even 13 or 12
years old you've probably seen enough
superhero origin stories to make you
want to throw up so Deadpool does the
smart thing of saying okay we get it
you've seen this before so we're gonna
mess around with this formula yeah not a
lot of people know as much about
Deadpool as they do about Batman
Superman even
Iron Man Thor or any of the Avengers
characters and they find this really
nice balance where they feed you all the
information on his backstory while at
the same time winking at you going yeah
yeah we get it you know where this is
headed let's fast-forward and there's
very literally a fast-forward at a
certain point it's beautiful I totally
love it one of the other really big
reasons that I love Deadpool is that it
doesn't try to be bigger than it needs
to be it's a very small film it's not
like Avengers age of Ultron where you
stuff every single thing that Marvel has
including their kitchen sink in you have
a couple minor x-men characters couple
things from the x-men universe in
Deadpool with his core cast of
characters like blind owl can't do
Deadpool movie without blind al and I
know I didn't mention it but the actors
the Placer does an amazing job I feel
like what I want them to do for the
sequel is keep it just as small as it is
but swap cable in like I actually do a
Deadpool in cable movie but without
making it really timey wimey like x-men
Days of Future past trying to jump
forward to the future I'm not expecting
Deadpool to all sudden go to the future
if they do end up doing Deadpool on
cable cable would totally come to
present-day and it'd still be a
relatively small film I think if they
want to go big with Deadpool they just
stick them in the x-force movie which I
think will happen it just I don't know
how big he's gonna be in that film it
depends on how much they want to budget
for it there are a whole lot of jokes
about things in the film that are
missing because their budget is really
small so now the big one for Deadpool
but like I said with the rated arch
stuff they mix those jokes in with
really meaningful or really WTF moments
so you have to balance the film out it
can't all just be Spider Man
wisecracking with swords if you're
unfamiliar from behind the scenes when
Rob Liefeld was creating him he pitched
him as Spider Man with swords because
Spider Man obviously biggest comic-book
character on the planet so he did
wisecracking spider-man with a suit that
looked like spider-man's with a job like
Deathstroke because he was a huge
Deathstroke fan so him being in a mall
guv him a couple of really big
characters also feeds into the fact that
he makes a lot of meta pop-culture jokes
and surprisingly you guys can let me
know what you thought about this but I
feel like the way they shot the film in
the types of jokes that they did don't
date it like you'll be able to watch
this in 10 years and be like what's he
talking about
who's that popstar that he mentioned
there isn't any of that and there are a
lot of jokes about old people that are
still playing superheroes
I'll say about that is that Hugh Jackman
is a trooper he is definitely a team
player in a true friend so do whatever
you can to scrape a couple dollars
together to go see this film in theaters
that's really the best way to support
the film so what I'm probably gonna do
is wait a couple more days then do my
spoilery Deadpool video with Easter eggs
they're supposed to be over a hundred so
I'm probably at to see it three or four
times to catch them all there's some
really obvious ones so I might do that
first I might break it into a couple
different videos but see how many you
can spot and be careful about posting
spoilers in the comments because most of
the people watching this video might not
have seen the film yet plenty more
Deadpool come in so be sure to subscribe
to get everything and if there's like a
special of Deadpool comic book video
that you guys want me to do be sure to
let me know in the comments I know it
seems like Thursdays are normally kind
of like a boring day not a lot happens
but there was new Game of Thrones teaser
there was a Batman V Superman trailer so
in case you guys haven't seen that you
can click here for the Game of Thrones
teaser video that I just did and you can
click here for the Batman V Superman
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody you know baby sighs high-five
winking behind the camera I'll see you
guys tonight
you